all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are picking back up again
with the joker i don't know how many of
you guys recall we covered the first
four issues a little while back
uh so we're gonna add this to the batman
playlist right i mean i feel like the
joker's had so few series over the years
there's not really a reason to make a
playlist unto himself with
two videos in it so uh here's the thing
in the last video we basically ended
kind of in the modern era right with
this point where you had
the joker who was basically being
tracked down by the daughter of bane uh
this one actually kind of flashes back
and it basically gives us this sort of
secret origin
of the joker these things that we didn't
know and it actually focuses on the
joker's first night in arkham asylum
which is
really cool because we never really saw
how that played out so i definitely dig
it now again a lot of the joker's
stories or really most of the joker's
story is told from the perspective of
commissioner gordon and that's really
where we pick up right that at some
point
in the past that commissioner gordon has
has largely had this really interesting
story going on with his character
where's kind of been this juxtaposition
between how he was when he first arrived
in gotham from chicago
and then like how he is now and how much
things have changed and one of the
things that he says is that he had an
old partner in chicago that said there
were only two kinds of people in the
world
those who ended up in the right place at
the right time and those who ended up in
the wrong place at the wrong time and
for the longest period of his life he
thought it was kind of nonsense right
that there's
more than two types of people in the
world and surely it's not circumstantial
like that
then he arrived in gotham city and while
gotham was not really the cesspool that
we know it to be now
at the time that commissioner gordon
arrived it was getting to that point
that largely you had the falcone crime
family and things like that so it was
really it almost seemed like a hold over
from the old days of the mob right you
know pretty boy floyd elk of home those
guys as opposed to you know what it
would become
with like the joker and with two-face
and penguin and all those different guys
and so that's why he kind of tells it in
retrospect that looking back on his life
when he first arrived here he was one of
the guys who was in the wrong place at
the wrong time
and so the way this plays out is there's
there's really a couple cops who have
basically been
you know caught up or snatched up by
some guy one of them has been shot and
the other one is basically being held
hostage now
there is commissioner gordon a couple
guys on the scene but gordon at this
point in his life is a captain he's not
really a commissioner yet so i just call
the commissioner because
honestly i'm just used to saying
commissioner gordon but gordon ends up
busting in there now
this is a big deal because at the time
it was a way for gordon to kind of
establish look i'm not just some captain
who's gonna sit idly by and let guys get
shot right that's one of the things
about gordon
is he's always been exceedingly adamant
about protecting his cops right that
when it comes to the various captains
and even when he became commissioner of
the police department he would go to the
ends of the earth to make sure
that his boys would never be injured in
that way or at least wouldn't be left
hanging and so this is really where a
lot of that starts when he goes busting
into this room there's basically this
this henchman that's got a gun in his
hand
going to shoot a cop and commissioner
gordon you know tackles him and they go
flying out of a window
right and so kind of picking up after
that he's met by harvey dent now again
this is before harvey dent becomes
two-faced and that's one of the cool
things about this this kind of story is
because despite the fact that they're
written in completely different eras
the reality is you could probably read
this story and then go read the long
halloween and basically get like the new
origin of harvey dent the important
thing here
is that harvey again was never really an
enemy of gordon right he was not really
an enemy of the police department it's
one of the big differences for those of
you guys who saw like christopher
nolan's dark knight trilogy that's one
of the big differences and one of the
things that i thought was kind of
intriguing is
from time to time you would see harvey
operate in that way but more often than
not
especially in these early days he was a
friend of gordon right and he was a
friend of the police department in a lot
of instances
and so that's one of the things that he
kind of says right when they're talking
he's like look i mean
what you did was heroic man right you're
the hero of the hour i mean like that
guy would have been shot had you not
jumped through there and tackled that
guy through a window and sure he's
probably gonna sue you for excessive
force but we're the cops right we have
ways to solve problems like that and so
it's one of these these these weird
things right because in this kind of
conversation that the two of them are
having
that there's also this idea that this
guy had basically spilled a bunch of
information
about what was going on at music kelly
towers that basically there'd be a way
for them to crack down
on the crime family right specifically
on falcone that there's some kind of a
huge deal that's supposed to be going
down at these towers and this guy
spilled the beans basically sets the
stage for them to be able to interrupt
that that deal
and just kind of bust everything now the
funny thing about that is these guys
immediately
approach it from a little bit of
skepticism and that's just common sense
right that's just intelligent thinking
you have to be some kind of fool to be
like yeah man this guy
who's who's got like he's a career
criminal this guy told me a great big
huge deal is going down
surely we can trust him and so it's kind
of like i mean this is the
one thing to be aware of this could be a
trap right it's entirely possible this
guy's setting us up
and we're going out there and they're
going to kill as many cops as they
possibly can that's entirely possible
but at the end of the day
if the juice is worth the squeeze right
they're like i mean we can't let this
kind of opportunity
pass us by we've got to do something and
so at that point the conversation shifts
over to the joker and the way this plays
out it really comes off the heels of the
old school
you know red hood story for those of you
guys who recall not jason todd redhood
but the story where the joker operated
under the mantle of red hood so you
could call it the killing joke if you
want to uh but whichever
whatever origin you agree with at the
end of the day it all kind of comes down
to the joker being apprehended or at
least the guy who would become the joker
being apprehended by batman and then
basically throwing an arkham asylum the
big difference here is that this is not
really based
on that tried and true origin most of
those origins when it comes to the joker
usually
involve the idea of him just kind of
being some unsuspecting or some
unwitting individual who was part of a
criminal scheme and it wasn't until
later when he was dumped in the vat of
chemicals and all that kind of stuff
that he became the joker specifically if
you cite the killing joke and so what
this does is it kind of hits on this
idea that the joker's engaged in a
series of schemes already and instead of
just being thrown
or at least kind of getting away
whatever the case is that he's being put
in arkham asylum and so we know at this
point the joker's been operating
for a little while but it's the first
time he's in arkham
the other part of this and this is one
of the big issues when it comes to
gordon
is that somewhere along the line we knew
that there were struggles between the
relationship of his wife himself and his
kids that things were pretty strained
and in the later years we knew that they
basically split up but we didn't know
exactly how all this stuff kind of went
down
this all started with small little
things when he's talking to harvey dent
and he's like okay tomorrow we can get
together we can go and and check out
this bus and try to grab some of
falcone's guys possibly even arrest
falcone himself you know bring him in on
charges of whatever was that he was
doing whatever he was smuggling and then
we'll essentially bring down the entire
falcone crime family which is which
would be a
that's a career bust those of you guys
who don't know when it comes to police
officers you have what are called career
bus which is basically a bust you make
or an arrest you make that makes your
career right that kind of solidifies
you're the guy that has it where it
counts and you're the guy they want to
see
in an upper level position and so
ultimately that night is supposed to be
his night off and he's like well i mean
crime doesn't sleep but like my kids
will so it's one of these things where
like his family is kind of starting to
take a back seat to all the stuff that
he has going on right to his idea as a
police officer
trying to fight crime that's becoming
the foremost thing in his life and so
you pick up with a bit of a therapy
session not a whole lot going on here
and it's just one of these things where
commissioner gordon is is not
necessarily blowing it off but it's just
kind of like i mean this
meeting's running a little long you know
i got places to be it's obvious he's
only there because his wife
wants him to be there right that's
that's kind of the the obvious situation
here and so what you end up doing
is you transition over to arkham asylum
now this is kind of interesting here
because once you get to arkham as you
guys know jeremiah arkham is the one
who's running it at this particular
point in time
and you have a guy that jim gordon calls
frank and he says actually my name is mr
frank that's going to be important later
on it's one of those where it's kind of
like we run the show here not you
so it's kind of establishing dominance
to a degree uh and then in turn of
course you end up coming across
billy sampson now a lot of you guys may
recall from the previous video that we
did
that billy samson was basically the guy
who killed nate people
and that ultimately he was put in here
now of course we learned a little more
behind the scenes
that he essentially took the rap for his
family and that he has been provided the
cell
in a secure wing of arkham that was
built explicitly for him so he could
basically spend his days in arkham
asylum in the lap of luxury and so this
is when you end up coming across
jeremiah arkham now as most of you guys
know jeremiah arkham this guy was just
sleazy right like this
you could look at that guy and tell
there was something off about him right
he was always just a little suspicious
and that's one of the things that you
kind of get here
is that when you when you have jim
gordon talking to arkham he's like look
man
i get this guy billy sampson did some
stuff but this guy's drugged out beyond
his own imagination right like this guy
is never going to hurt anybody like you
literally filled him up with all kinds
of different drugs i mean this guy would
have to go cold turkey for months
in order to in order to get himself
cleared up and by that point in time
you he would probably die of shock if
you shine a light in his eyes right i
mean like that guy
this guy's gone right i mean there's no
way he's gonna go back to any real
measure of being normal so take him out
of this this wing
and put the joker in here instead and
the reason why is because commissioner
gordon
almost immediately after he met the
joker began to realize
there was something different about that
guy and that's something that he's been
constantly trying to reiterate
to all the people who were here to
jeremiah arkham to mr frank
even to like harvey dent and even to the
court itself right to the police
department to the higher ranking
officials
this guy is not some average dude who
committed some crimes and did some stuff
this guy's a serious threat right this
guy's a legitimate deal
and you have to treat him that way you
can't just throw him in some section of
arkham asylum with no real measure of
security beyond what you provide for
anybody else out there
and just call it a day he's not some
crazy person who refuses to wear green
because that's how the cia finds him
this guy's nuts
this guy's got problems right so again
it's one of these things where even
arkham goes as far as to say look like
we're not taking him out of the cell the
whole reason why this cell exists is
because his brother donated a ton of
money to arkham arkham asylum and
this cell was one of the conditions and
his brother staying in here was is one
of the conditions so the only way to get
him to move is to get his brother to ask
him to be moved and so you have this
this kind of conversation between jim
gordon and billy sampson's brother and
billy sampson's brother just kind of
shuts this down with the quickness he's
like look man i don't really care right
like this guy is gonna be taken care of
that's just the way it is there's not
gonna be any kind of situation where
he's moved or anything like that i don't
care what case you make
this guy's not going anywhere right he's
staying exactly where he is and that's
all there is to it and so what you end
up getting is commissioner gordon who
basically spends the night with the
joker now
after 11 minutes of recording we get to
this bit of a
the whole thing with the joker himself
right because that's one of the cool
things it's kind of a slow bit of a
story here
commissioner gordon stays behind at
arkham asylum and decides to watch the
joker because he sees him as being so
incredibly dangerous
more so than that there's a point where
like all these guys just kind of come
running out of the cafeteria and when
jim gordon goes in there he's like what
in the heck is going on and he's like
he's like where's the joker at and mr
frank's like he's in the cafeteria
and the joker's just sitting there right
just eating some cake and he's like
captain gordon what a lovely surprise i
didn't know you were mentally ill what
happened to your head man like it's just
one of these things where the joker's
just kind of there and doing stuff
more so than that where he's eating this
pie right just kind of you know kind of
eating this dessert mr frank is like you
got to go back right and even even
commissioner gordon's like you got to go
back to yourself and joker says you know
well francis i'm still hungry and then
gordon is like no his name's mr frank
and then mr frank responds actually he's
correct
my name is francis right off the bat
joker's manipulating people right that's
the nature of the joker he's the most
extreme version of a sociopath he's not
a psychopath right that's one of the
important
distinctions if you're going to read the
dsm jugger doesn't does not qualify as a
psychopath he qualifies as a sociopath
an extreme sociopath but a sociopath
with psychosis nonetheless and so it's
one of these things where like
commissioner gordon starts to realize
this guy's basically he like he's been
manipulating everybody the entire time
harvey dent
the court systems judge the whole nine
yards like everybody's been manipulated
by the joker and the joker tries that to
a degree
on commissioner gordon but that's one of
the things to know is that even in the
early days of the joker right these
early depictions here
that he really hasn't changed all that
much in relation to how he functions
that he's still manipulative he's still
full of tricks and lies and things like
that
but it's done in a very very smooth and
very very low key way
right it's not hypnotism we're looking
too mirage it's not anything like that
right it's just using wordplay and
getting under people's skin
and you know getting a feel for them and
in some ways even making himself
extremely approachable that's one of the
things about the joker he's
highly charismatic that's how he managed
to swindle harley quinn right was just
being an exceedingly charismatic person
that basically told her everything she
wanted to hear
and made himself to look like a great
guy a victim who's been abused by batman
and
suddenly the two of them were just kind
of caught caught in a whole scheme
together and they were working together
for years and years and years and that's
one of the things that he says to uh to
to commissioner gordon is damn like i'm
really in your head aren't i like
i was kidding before but like it's true
right and you can't figure out why
can you and so what happens is gordon
just like kind of positions a chair
that just sits outside the cell of of
the joker and that's when you get like
this amazing monologue from the jokers
that's one of the things
if the joker's written right dude he's
amazing
if he's written bad it's terrible right
it's absolutely awful but when he's
written well he's written well and
that's what you get here right like it's
one of these things where he's kind of
like you know i think i know why i'm in
your head all the time gordon because
you live
in a world that is a normal world right
you see the world as being a normal
place you look at criminals and you see
people who rob
and people who steal and people who kill
and you know do all kinds of different
things
and that there are some legitimately bad
people out there but most people who
commit crimes commit crimes out of
desperation
right like who wouldn't kill for their
kids who wouldn't steal for their kids
who wouldn't do any of those things to
protect their family and so you can see
a little piece of yourself and all these
people here there's criminals out there
that just piss you off and so in your
desire to kill them you imagine what it
would be like if you just
killed that guy so you could see
yourself in the the face of a murderer
right you could see yourself in these
different circumstances but you look at
me
and you can't see yourself in me you
can't see yourself
as being a part of me there's nothing
about me that you find
remotely relatable i take pleasure in
the suffering of other people
and there's there's nothing about that
that you can relate to and in the
beginning
you took solace in that you took comfort
in the fact that you could not see
yourself in the face of a man like me
because it means you could never become
a man like me he's a freak he's an
anomaly it's one of these weird things
that are out there but then suddenly you
started to look at me and you started to
realize how does a person become that
way how does a person get to a point
where they are a normal functioning
human being that exists in this world
and their parents give them a moral
compass and they go forward from there
to becoming someone like the joker and
the more you think about that the more
that you consider that the more you
begin to realize
i'm just the first that something bad is
coming to gotham city yeah i'm not this
big hurricane that you're afraid of i'm
just the first dark cloud on the horizon
but it's only ever gonna get worse it's
only ever gonna get worse and worse and
worse and worse and that's when it
suddenly occurs to commissioner gordon
the whole deal with falcone and harvey
dent and so he basically you know like
literally tells this guy keep an eye on
the door do not let joker get out he
runs out to the police car tries to
radio harvey he can't really pick up a
signal on the radio and so he's like
okay fine whatever so he ends up going
back into arkham and like the the guy
who's supposed to be standing there is
gone he ends up having to go to the
bathroom
but the joker's not in the cell anymore
and so of course you know like literally
you have commissioner gordon just starts
running through the entirety of arkham
only to find the joker sitting in the
kitchen
eating some pie and so from there it's
again just one of these things where the
joker's kind of talking to commissioner
gordon and seemingly talking to him all
night long
and so of course gordon wakes up at like
six o'clock in the morning and then
of course you have jeremiah arkham in
them who are there who are like okay man
like it's time for you to go home right
like you need to leave here but as he's
leaving he ends up you know kind of
hearing this radio broadcast where there
is a search for the music kelly tower
shooting and that it's expanding beyond
the original scope and so when gordon
gets to where he was supposed to meet
with harvey dent that's when he finds
out it really was a trap right it really
was a trap set by
by falcone on behalf of this guy we
don't know how deep it went if this guy
was supposed to get busted in order to
like set the cops up in a trap but
regardless harvey then ended up taking a
handful of guys to the towers and they
all got shot up it was a massacre and
harvey dent
immediately lashes out at jim gordon so
this right here explains why harvey
doesn't like gordon but
but he basically lashes out he's like
had it not been for you if you had been
there
then none of this would have happened
right like you should have been there
you were supposed to be here
all of our guys got massacred like you
were supposed to be the one that
provided the voice of reason you've got
this kind of scent when it comes to
these kinds of things
you're supposed to give us a perspective
right at the very least you would have
known that we should have pulled out we
needed you and you were nowhere to be
found
because you couldn't let the joker thing
go and so of course jim gordon ends up
basically leaving
and heading back home and he has this
really really cool kind of a
of a little speech to himself where he
says harvey dent is a good man i can't
blame him
for what he said but he's wrong and the
joker was right i don't know what it is
i don't understand it but something
awful is growing in gotham and if we
want to stand any chance against it then
i was exactly where i needed to be last
night and this is the important thing
because
that night was the anniversary between
him and his wife he basically
blew off his anniversary and the
entirety of his family to babysit the
joker what started out as a concern
has now turned into an obsession with
commissioner gordon but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace
you